protests have broken out across the
Netherlands over a controversial
traditional Christmas character called
Black Pete celebrations featuring the
character have come in for increasing
criticism in recent years with
accusations that it encourages racial
stereotypes
[Applause]
well black Piet has been a part of Dutch
Christmas festivities since the mid 19th
century when he first appeared in a
children's book he said to be the
trusted helper of father Christmas
climbing down chimneys to deliver
presents and sweets to children in
parades and other appearances black
Petes is played by an adult wearing
black makeup a curly wig and colorful
clothes well this year's protests follow
years of complaints and censorship of
black Piet both in the Netherlands and
abroad in 2011 a Dutch Christmas
celebration was canceled in a small
Canadian town after complaints of racism
in 2015 several Dutch cities altered
black Petes image slightly for parades
putting suits on his cheeks rather than
full blackface and then a school in the
Canadian capital Ottawa decided to
remove black Petes altogether out of
respect for the diversity of its
students and a month ago Dutch
broadcaster NTR ditched the blackface
version of the character instead opting
for soot marks but opinions are mixed in
the Netherlands we stand here to protest
because we find the idea of black Piet
racist who want us to change so the
festivities are pleasant for everyone I
think it's a big fest for the kids and
the case I don't see if the repeat is
black or white or it's cold
I think it's it's an on discussion for
me I think that we should keep the
festivities as they are and keep black
Pete I see no point in having a white
Pete after all this is for children or
journalists Luke
reveille says it's hard for people to
change long-held traditions but people
need to move at the times go so far it's
it would be it will be very difficult to
defend this tradition but it I remember
vividly in the first day of my primary
school you know being scared of this guy
who had his brawling eyes coming to us
it was a white man in a black face but
he was the interesting character not
Saint Nicholas you know the Saint okay
it was a nice old man but we were are
more interested by this person with the
big rolling eyes so um it's it's
impossible I think to continue as is but
originally it is not racism at all we
live in a funny world where the
political correctness is becoming
incredible things evolve and obviously
with the outcry in the Netherlands you
cannot keep as far to Pete on Black Pete
ases it's it's unfortunate for those who
love traditions but so it is
you